pendant ce temps le modem tient ce
week-end ses universités de rentrée dans
le var
changement de stratégie pour le modem
fini l'antisarkozysme cap sur 2012
françois bayrou compte jouer la carte du
rassemblement karine lejeune terre
noureddine tard le bayrou nouveau est
arrivé
son gouvernement fictif derrière lui le
président du modem est venu faire mentir
ses détracteurs
non il n'est pas seul nous sommes en
ordre de marche
nous avons formé nos équipes et nous
allons évidemment avec toutes celles et
tous ceux qui sont là affronter la
situation difficile du pays
le secteur de l'agriculture est confiée
à marc chesneau maire de marchenoir
présidente jean luc bennahmias puis est
nommé au fond ministère de la jeunesse
et des sports
marielle de sarnez elle récupère
fièrement un autre portefeuille
je suis en charge de tout ce qui relève
des affaires étrangères et la
gouvernance internationale voilà qui
sont des sujets que j'aime un jeu de
rôle
placée sous le signe de l'espoir a mieux
c'est l'anti sarkozysme qu'il faut
françois bayrou qui avait signé il ya
trois ans un brûlot contre le président
de la république
reina aujourd'hui jouer la carte des
valeurs parmi les valeurs dont nous
avons besoin
la vérité est la première et le
rassemblement et la seconde des valeurs
et de l'espoir pour les militants malgré
les derniers revers électoraux
pour l'instant il n'y a pas énormément
de personnes sur l'échiquier politique
qui sont capables de redonner de
l'espoir ils sont capables d'expliquer
aux français
pendant la france ça sera peut-être dur
il faut papon sacrifices qu'on pense
sous prétexte ça nous donnera des
chances d'être élu et pour être élu
françois bayrou se dit prêt aujourd'hui
à accepter un rassemblement au centre
en revanche et il rejette toute alliance
officielle avec dominique de villepin
d'autres ouvertures significatifs
pourraient avoir lieu après le
remaniement